hi ever wait oh I do have the sidearm
you up what hi you know just Sunni
weapon do you have a lemme see any
weapon let me come here all right where
are you where are you you area what is
it what is it we're gonna get teleported
out without of here though wait wait
let's wait there it is what is what it
is you you ran away I read I was since
my home shoot me at it shoot me ok so
what is so it's like a little it's like
a little is like a it's like a cannon
yeah it's like a fast firing pistol a
starting pistol yeah sidearm we tell a
sidearm what sort of fancy things does
that do oh man kills bad got any
different things it has all right little
perk against oh oh oh yeah oh god no we
got some stragglers round them up still
got some escapees go find him yeah they
are better the whole bunch night get out
of here yeah all right orbital bro
waiting for us see if this is gonna come
out in the middle again that's to tell
us oh yeah yeah yeah I'm in a bad spot
I'm in a really bad place yeah get it
I'm out of heavens master yes I do have
heavy hi fi biggie hey sup